ufc and boxing world obviously you know
cross paths sometimes
uh have you have you heard anything
about uh a tyson comeback
i heard some some rumblings of him maybe
joining bare knuckle fighting
and uh damn yeah bro that's brutal i've
been to a few of their shows i've been
to one out here in miami and i've
i've been to one in mississippi and dude
that's
hard to watch man and i love fights and
i've been to thousands of fights
sitting ringside and watching these guys
bump knuckles oh man
it's it's does it take you back to a
does it take you back to a time like in
the beginning of your career or is it
just a totally different ball game
yeah it's it's a you know i've never
fought bare knuckle
uh only in street fights you know but
i've never fought a sanctioned bare
knuckle fight
only at mardi gras huh oh dude yeah
that's why i don't even go to mardi gras
anymore man
yeah dude in louisiana bro yeah you
too many guys want to uh too many fake
mike perry's want to show up you know
yeah yeah i don't want them problems man
i don't know but i know they uh bare
knuckle also fight uh signed a former
world champion shannon briggs a guy
out here in florida so if if tyson does
sign to bear knuckle i mean these are
two
legitimate heavyweight champions of the
world
that could fight bear knuckle would be
it would be madness wow
that'd be crazy to see tyson bare
knuckle dude he's 50 something years old
oh
blend somebody up it looks like right
the way he's moving oh man each one of
his knuckles is like a fist
they say uh power's the last thing to go
really when you're aging as a fighter
yeah power's the last thing to go
damn and that's what he had the most of
all power yeah
i'm just sitting on your front porch
wondering how could i be
so far from my home
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been